[Music]
President Obama spoke at MIT on Friday
and immediately began rewriting history
he made the claim that his
administration was scandal-free thanks
to the magical power of diversity
running guns to Mexican cartels didn't
happen weaponized in the IRS and the FBI
against political opponents fake news
well Obama has been patting himself on
his back the party he shattered is
searching for a champion in the next
election Fox's Juan Williams just argued
in an opinion piece the president
Trump's three strongest challengers
would all be African American women
Oprah Michelle Obama and senator Kamala
Harris of California is it true Fox
senior political analyst Brit Hume joins
us tonight but it so the first question
thanks for coming on is is that true do
you think diversity kept Barack Obama's
two terms entirely scandal-free well I
don't think it wasn't tally scandal-free
you just mentioned a couple of examples
and then there's a another one a kind of
a Haller and that is his Secretary of
State so recklessly mishandled
classified information that she was very
nearly indicted and many legal experts
think she should have been I would rate
that as a pretty big scandal I don't
think diversity had anything to do with
it one way or another but it certainly
argues I guess yeah I did it was
scandal-free it wasn't it's funny though
I mean the the former president and and
didn't really do his credit I mean he
hasn't been I mean this was apparently
an off-the-record comment that got
reported he hasn't been in the news
really and I think that's exactly a
former president should be not around
however it seems a little early to start
rewriting the history of an
administration that just ended doesn't
it well look at all presidents try to
see their administration's and the most
favorable possible light and he's
looking back on his and I'm sure he's
looking at the man in the white house
and trying to create a contrast with him
because Obama whatever you whether you
like him or not did behavior himself
with a certain dignity and grace that
some have found lacking in Donald Trump
clearly Obama has found that lacking in
Donald Trump and I think he'd like to
contrast his performance in office with
that of mr. Trump but to say that his
administration is scandal-free is
nonsense yeah it is so there was a piece
this week by our colleague and friend
Juan Williams I'm not signaling him out
a lot of people have basically written
but said that the the three main
challengers to President Trump who made
in effect announcement said he's running
again three years from now would be
Oprah Michelle Obama and commonly harris
of california all three black women what
struck me about this was the way it was
framed in the way so many of these
conversations are framed they primarily
turn on questions of race and gender is
that the future do you think of American
politics identity politics well as soon
as the future of the Democratic Party
needs the present of the Democratic
Party that it looks at things that way
that's and being a woman and being a
minority it would be an important
credential for nomination in the
Democratic Party it doesn't mean you
won't that doesn't mean you're gonna get
the nomination but it gives you a leg up
it gave Hillary Clinton a leg up and
enabled her to to to fight off the
rather significant challenge from a
geriatric socialist in the person of
Bernie Sanders one might have thought
that would have been easy but such as
the Democratic Party today there wasn't
easy at all and if you're looking ahead
to 2020 whoever it is is likely to need
to have quite leftist credentials in
order to you know touch the heart of the
Democratic Party which is part of the
left of where it used to be I think all
three of the women described I'm not
really sure where Oprah is on all the
issues I really haven't looked into a
great carefully because I doubt she's
gonna run Kamala Harris has certainly
shown herself to be quite liberal and
certainly Michelle Obama would be seen
in that light as well I think Kamala
Harris by the way it would be an
interesting candidate she has a tendency
to make gaffes and say particularly
amazing things for example she said that
Sheriff Arpaio should not have been
pardoned because he'd committed a crime
well madam that's why he needed to be
pardoned she also said that it was long
to say that the dreamers were unlawful
well that's part of the definition of
what the dreamers are they're they came
here and are here illegally and that's
why we're trying to you know so many
people are working so hard to try to
find a way to keep them here there
wouldn't be something to deportation if
they weren't unlawful but such as Carla
Harris I think Michelle Obama Tucker
would be an imposing candidate hmm
interesting so I mean can we just be
totally honest and say that you know
Terry McAuliffe was making noises about
running the other day and there are a
number of people who look like Terry
McAuliffe saying they're gonna run as
Democrat
nobody like terry mcauliffe is gonna get
the nomination this time I mean no I
don't think I think Terry McAuliffe is
yeah he's too much I think Kara
McAuliffe would probably be seen as too
much of a creature of the Democratic
Party as it once was under Bill Clinton
and later under Hillary Clinton and I
don't think that's where the Democratic
Party is now for consider this Tucker
Diane Feinstein was just Dianne
Feinstein who's you know not a liberal
on everything but a liberal or nearly
everything it was just denied the the
endorsement of the Democratic Party in
California and and in and dan Lipinski
who is a congressman from the southwest
side of Chicago or just his district
also includes some of the suburbs there
was just given the heave-ho by the
Democratic Congressional Campaign
Committee and his re-election bid in
favor of a more liberal candidate this
is where that party is going and if
you're going to win a nomination in this
party in 2020 in my estimation you're
gonna have to be pretty far out there
and you know that's right Elizabeth
Warren you might have the credentials
you might not have the right skin color
but Michelle Obama might indeed fit the
bill I think it's been an undercover
story for a long time and I appreciate
that
a Britain I think you're right good to
see you you bet